halli Hallo liebe Leute meinen ersten
Auftritt in der Lindenstraße am 17 juni
1850 im ersten nicht vergessen
einzuschalten feiern wir mit einem ganz
besonderen Gewinnspiel es gibt nämlich
nichts Geringeres zu gewinnen als ein
ngel Nagel neues iPad und die DVD
Kollektion der Lindenstraße und alles
was ihr machen müsst ist die
Lindenstraße gucken nee nicht ganz ihr
müsst eine Frage beantworten und zwar in
welcher Location in der Lindenstraße
findet die Szene von K1 der war mich
dabei und mir dort statt und wenn das
wisst schreibt eine Mail an
gewinnspiel@lindenstraße.de bis zum 22
Juni dann ist der Einsendeschluss und
wenn er das gemacht habt da habt ihr
eine gute Chance diesen Preis zu
gewinnen und ich drück allen die Daumen
und ansonsten immer mal wieder
Lindenstraße gucken weil ab und zu taue
ich da jetzt auf ansonsten bis dann
bleib
dran